-Our first guest tonight
hosts "Alex Wagner Tonight"
Tuesdays through Fridays
at 9:00 p.m. on MSNBC.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend Alex Wagner,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
-You got to do the live
coverage thing last night.
-I sure did. Five hours.
-Five hours. Well done.
Five hours.
I feel like that
gives you a lot of time
to develop some takes on it.
-Especially when they call
the election like an hour in.
-An hour in.
-Yes.
-This does seem like a night
that was maybe...
bad for both of them.
Do you feel like
there's anything to that?
-I'm a glass half full
kind of gal.
Maybe good for both of them
or ultimately bad.
I think it was...
I mean, it's bad for Trump
as far as the general election,
right?
-Yeah.
-It's very clear
that college-educated voters,
independents do not
like Donald Trump.
He attracts his base and repels
independents in equal measure.
Um, you know,
I think for Joe Biden it is --
Are you talking about them?
You're talking
about Biden and...?
-No, I'm talking about
Haley and Trump.
You'll have to excuse me.
-Sorry.
My mind is on the general.
-[ Indistinct ]
-For Nikki Haley,
like, it's good that
she did well among people
who actually aren't a huge part
of the Republican primary
electorate.
It would be great if she could
make it to the general election,
but she's not going to.
-Yeah.
-It was a bad night for her.
-And now, you know, again,
we saw him,
and we just showed a clip.
She came after him pretty hard
about his, uh,
electability problems
in a general.
-Yes.
-Do you feel like her...
The rest of the field
before they dropped out,
do you feel like
they made a mistake
not making that case earlier?
-Can I just say
just to put a fine point
on, like, criticizing Trump?
Yes, she makes a point
about his cognitive decline.
She makes a point about
how he's not a kingmaker
in contested tight elections.
But there are a lot
of big elephants in the room
that she doesn't talk about.
Like, I don't know,
shredding the Constitution,
saying he wants to be
a dictator on day one
and undermining democracy.
-Yeah.
-That stuff, like...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...I maintain...
she hasn't really gone
for the jugular.
But, you know,
in this sort of modern GOP,
the very fact that
she's willing to utter,
you know, the fact that he's
a fallible candidate makes her,
I guess, singular
at this stage of the game.
I don't think it's possible
to win in the Republican primary
unless you are Donald Trump.
-Yeah.
-I really think that, you know,
for her to have gone
to be full-throated consistently
as a critic of Donald Trump
would have disqualified her
even earlier, you know,
and I think we saw that
with Chris Christie
and anyone else
who even semi sort of tried.
-So now she's in a situation
where maybe she tries to hang on
because she is running against
somebody who has 91 indictments.
He could be in a situation
where, who knows.
-The rapture, as we call it.
-Absolutely.
-The rapture may come, yeah.
-There's never been a candidate
where there seems like
there's more reasons
he might have to step aside.
Does she play the long game now
and stick around --
even though, let's be honest,
she's not going to win a state?
-No.
I mean, she will have some...
She will have some electors
to her name.
DeSantis I think
has like four or five.
She's the only person who could
theoretically take the crown
if he's convicted.
But, I mean, I'm hesitant
to get people's hopes up,
people who are not detractors
of Donald Trump,
that somehow Nikki Haley
could pull this thing out.
I mean, it would really have
to be a rapture-like scenario.
I see the numbers that,
you know, a sizable portion
of the New Hampshire electorate
doesn't think Donald Trump
is fit to be president
if he's convicted.
But, like, we've got
a long way to go before,
A, there's a trial,
B, there's a conviction
and the appeals process is over.
And Donald Trump
is going to spend
a lot of time
on the courtroom steps,
spinning this all up
into a partisan witch hunt.
And the Republican electorate
has proven very permeable
to that kind of argument.
-Well, that's a good
point about exit polls.
It does seem that is a very easy
way to voice your frustration
and say "I will not
support this candidate."
And then all of a sudden
it's a general election,
and there's only
one candidate left
who supports your party.
Do you buy the people
who say this on the way
out of the polling booth
that they'll never support him?
Or do you think they do
come around?
-I mean, I think there are --
there are some people
left in the Republican Party --
I don't know why they're still
in the Republican Party,
to be honest -- that still care
about democracy and integrity.
-Yeah.
-Right?
-Then I think there's some
people that are asked,
like, when they're coming
out of voting,
"Hey, do you think the president
should be a convict?"
And they're like, "No,"
because I think
that there's really
a disconnect
between that
sort of moral assessment
of what kind of character
we want from our president
and the reality of that being
Donald Trump, like, their guy.
And I think you're gonna see --
I don't like to be
a, you know, prognosticator,
but I'm in the business of it.
Uh, and I would imagine
you're going to see
that number shrink a little bit
just because of what I said,
like just atrophy, exhaustion,
Donald Trump
is going to spin this thing.
And then when it comes down
to brass tacks,
like,
what's the conviction, right?
Is it Stormy Daniels hush money?
Is it Mar-A-Lago documents?
Is it a federal election
interference case?
I think that all matters as well
in terms of people saying
"I'm not going to vote
for this dude."
-Now, obviously we're
in a situation
where I think the, you know,
the Democratic
electorate is worried.
There was a nervousness that
I think --
-You think?
-I do. I do.
But, I mean, I guess
there -- This comes back to it.
There just seems to be less
of a Republican Party
as there is just Donald Trump.
-It's a cult of personality.
-So there -- I guess we're not
going to see Republicans
freaking out in the same way,
because there are no Republicans
in the way we classically
think about it anymore
that matter, right?
It's Nikki Haley,
but I also believe that
if he turned around tomorrow
and asked her to be
his vice president,
I think she'd say yes.
-Oh, yeah.
Well, the devotion to Trump
is so singular
as to be almost
a religion, right?
So nothing else matters but him.
I mean, the only policy proposal
or the only policy he's
talked about is immigration,
which really feeds
on xenophobia and racism
more than a desire to fix
our broken immigration system.
So, yeah, I mean, I think
for them it is
the end all, be all is Trump and
nothing else matters.
For Biden, you know, look,
I think there is a lot of
trepidation
and concern about his age.
But, like, let's be real,
Biden has done a bang-up job
with the economy.
He has canceled
student loan debt.
He canceled more student
loan debt last week.
He has done more on climate than
any other American president.
I mean, his record,
given a one-seat majority
in the Senate, is bonkers.
And the fact that the dude
is old should not erase
what is a formidable record for
his first three years in office.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I agree.
What is the problem?
Why do you feel
like that message
is, one, maybe not effectively
getting out,
and, two, even when it's getting
out, not resonating with people?
-Vibes, Seth.
I've been told
it's the TikTok vibes.
-Yeah.
-But the vibes are changing.
I mean, the metrics
about consumer confidence
have gone up
I think like 15% to 20%
in the last couple of weeks,
so that's a good indicator
that maybe people
are finally catching on.
Part of it is narrative.
Part of it is miseducation
and redirection.
You know,
inflation's coming down.
I think that's the clearest,
most sort of pinpointable reason
why people don't feel
like the economy is good
because job creation, wages,
like, that stuff
is doing well
for almost everybody.
And I'm not even talking
about the stock market,
'cause that's not
most Americans.
But that thing is booming.
So, I mean,
I'm not a Biden spokesperson,
but I think, look,
there's a long way to go
between now and November,
and people's opinions
can change.
There could be
black swan events.
The rapture could come.
-Yeah.
-People feel differently about
this country month to month.
And the Biden team
is betting that people
are going to feel better
about the economy,
their place therein,
and feel a lot worse
about a narcissistic,
potentially convicted felon
being elected into office.
-It's not a
bad long-term plan.
-Yeah, I mean...
-So on a personal level,
you obviously -- you get to,
you know,
work on election night.
As you said, called an hour in,
not very dramatic.
Do you feel any heartache
about the fact that
you're not going to have sort of
a breathless primary season
of the horse-race politics
that do make good television,
but you're just not
going to get it?
-I know.
I mean, eating pizza,
cold pizza at 11:30 at night
with, like, under-eye concealer
flaking off your face.
I'm going to miss it.
No, it is -- Actually,
I am a little sad, not just --
I mean, let me just say, like,
the lament of the TV host.
Like, I don't get
to sit there on set
and make the big party happen.
I feel bad for democracy.
Like, it's a good -- Like,
200,000 people have voted.
We're a country of over
300 million people.
Like, it shouldn't be over now.
There should be debates
in the general election.
There should have been debates
in the primary season.
You know, maybe
it would have been nice
to have an open
Democratic primary
given all the misgivings
about Biden.
But, like, we get stronger
in those moments, not weaker.
And it's sad to me that
we're not going to have any...
-I agree with you 100%.
It does feel like we've all
just sort of checked out
on this idea.
And then people say, "You know,
I'm not really happy
with the two choices."
And you're like,
"Yeah, it's not..."
-Well,
as Rachel said last night,
there's not a lot of democracy
going on in this democracy
right now.
-Yeah. Well, we should get
some more democracy in here.
-Yeah. Well, can
someone bring it in?
-Alright, you and I,
let's get down to it.
-Bang.
-Thank you for being here.
It's always so good to see you.
Alex Wagner, everybody.
"Alex Wagner Tonight" airs
Tuesdays through Fridays
at 9 p.m. on MSNBC.
We'll be right back
with J. Smith-Cameron.